I want you to write me a
1,500word sales letter for my new
course. Oh, let's say my new
copywriting course
persuasion
secrets in the voice of John Carlton.
Love you
Johnny and
Alex Horosy.
Go. Let's see what it can do. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
[Music]
Huh boy.
We are
so cuckoo. All right. What's going on
guys? Alan Drago here. L Copy Go. And I
want to talk about this. I want to talk
about is AI going to replace copywriters
in 2025. The reason I'm asking this
question is because I had to ask myself
this question. A few weeks ago, I was
looking for a junior copywriter to join
my team. And in that process, I was
using AI to prompt some of the draft
work so I can get some of the tasks off
my plate. and I'll copy chief it later.
And what I ended up finding was that the
content was actually better than what I
was expecting from a junior copywriter.
So I said, "Hold the
phone. Am I going to hire a junior
copywriter right now or am I going to
hire somebody who understands
copywriting at a fundamental level that
can prompt, use this, and then I can
copy chief it?" And that got all my
wheels turning. And I started thinking
big picture philosophy. What is going to
happen? That leads me to the scary
truth. And the scary truth is I actually
think it's going to get worse before it
gets
better. But bear with me because I do
have a I think it's going to get better.
And I'll explain what that means. But
here's the reality. The reality is that
Chad GBT and Claude and Grock and all
these other platforms are more
accessible, faster, and affordable than
hiring a copywriter today and likely
will stay that way forever. Okay? They
can instantly open a browser. They can
do it for 20 bucks a month or free and
they can get the results instantly as
opposed to going up on Upwork or texting
a friend and then waiting for the copy
to be drafted. the copywriter asks a
bunch of questions, research, all these
things. You got to work with someone,
they don't deliver the results fast. All
of these things incur why it's going to
be really, really hard for junior
copywriters, entry- level copywriters to
actually step into the game now more
than ever because nobody is even
thinking about hiring a copywriter for
the first time. They're simply gonna go
to their
laptop. Claude's gonna do the work.
They're gonna ship it and move on with
their life. Not only that, but you could
take written courses like John Carlton's
kick-ass copyrighting. You can take my
email goat course. You could take $37
million headlines written by J. Abraham
and you can pump those into Claude and
say, "Okay, master this." And then it's
going to go pump out much better copy
than it initially would have pumped out.
And so now those are all the scary not
so good things that you need to think
about. But you have to think bigger
picture than just entrylevel copywriting
AI prompts right now. Okay, think about
this bigger picture. Think about the
copywriting industry. And this is where
I went down the rabbit hole for a while.
Okay, the copywriting industry. Bear it
down to its bare bones. We're not going
to stop using words, right? Words still
need to be written as well as sales.
Sales still need to happen. People still
want to sell stuff. Okay? So words exist
and sales exist. I.e. copywriting itself
will always exist. Excellent. So now you
have the two tensions of who's going to
be doing the copywriting. Is it going to
be AI bots or is it going to be humans
doing the copywriting? Okay. So that's
the copywriting industry. So copywriting
never going away. absolutely here to
stay forever and ever and ever and ever
and ever and ever. So, the industry is
solid, but who is in the industry?
That's what's on shaky ground. So, let's
break that down even more. And I'll tell
you exactly why I'm thinking this way.
As I just mentioned, for the time being,
I actually think the demand for
copywriting work in general will
continue to go down and down and down,
while AI copywriting will continue to go
up and up and up and up for the time
being. But you have to think about now
what happens next. Well, it's going to
historically repeat what always happens
when something like this occurs. Okay,
there is going to occur a
oversaturation in the copywriting
market. Okay, that oversaturation is
going to come from copywriting that is
coming from the same source. No matter
how you want to phrase it, no matter how
custom or how good your prompts are,
these large language learning models
like Claude and Chachypt and Grock are
algorithmically based, okay? They are
based in code. They are based on what
you feed it. Okay? So, it is a source of
information. That source has a code.
That code is a template. Okay? Those
things are formulas, frameworks, and
structures. And so when you have an
entire market that's getting overwhelmed
from the same source, imagine it as if
Gary Benga, the famous copywriter, had
written every single ad for all the
products in the 80s and '90s. Well, all
the ads would have a similar taste,
feel, structure, vibe to it. No, even
though there's nuances in different
markets and different prompts and all
this stuff, they would have the same
original source and so they would feel
the same. Other examples of this would
be like in the 2000s and 2010s when
every shoe looked like Nike even though
it was different brands. It was Adidas,
it was New Balance, it was all these
things, every shoe kind of looked like
Nike. They were following the Nike
trend. And then Kanye comes out of
nowhere, drops a Yeezy and it blows up.
It's called the Yeezy effect. Okay, this
is where it's going. It's going to an
oversaturated market temporarily, an
oversaturated market of
generalism. That generalism is sourced
from these AI large language learning
model. And what that is going to do is
it's going to create a brand new segment
of the
copywriting market. That's right.
Whenever there's an oversaturation of
one thing, what it does is it actually
creates opportunity to do a different
thing. Back to my Nike and Yeezys
example. When everything starts feeling
like Nike, Yeezy does the opposite and
completely destroys the entire industry,
takes over the entire market and becomes
a billiondoll brand almost overnight.
Then everybody copies Yeezys and the
next thing happens and so and so. So
it's Zigg and Zag. Zigg and Zach. Right
now, the market is zigging towards an AI
saturated market, which means there are
two things that you as a copywriter can
do to not be replaced by AI. Number one
is you can learn how to master this
entire AI ecosystem and put it to your
use, the speed, the efficiency, the
cost, and actually let it propel you to
do more work faster than ever for more
people. Do I think you're going for the
best quality work? No. But I think you
could saturate a lot of clients, a lot
of products, a lot of things, and you
can go for volume, which is candidly
what I would recommend for entry-level
copywriters. If you're an entry-level
copywriter trying to get clients, you
could basically price yourself lower
than the average market, do a lot more
stuff for that lower price, get a lot
more clients, you're leveraging a tool
to be able to do the work for you, so
you could do it faster and cheaper and
still make decent money. So, what that
means is if you're an entry-level
copywriter, you literally cannot compete
on price and deliverables anymore. You
can't be the same price as everybody
else and deliver the same exact things.
If you are an entry-level copywriter,
you have to be significantly cheaper and
you have to deliver significantly more
because you're using AI to leverage your
skill and time.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Does that mean that
you don't have to learn the
copyrightiting fundamentals? I mean, I
guess you could probably get by with it,
but I don't recommend against it.
Obviously, you should know what you're
shipping. But the more exciting
opportunity that I feel like is
happening in the copywriting industry is
less about the saturation and the
generalism, but what's about to explode
from it. What is the new thing that's
going to come out of this
oversaturation? Because everybody's
going to sound and look and feel like
AI. It's already happening. And so if
you're on the other side and you're not
necessarily an entry-level copywriter
like myself, you've been in the game for
a long time, I'm starting to spin my
wheels and think, okay, I myself have
two options and you even entry levels
becoming professionals have two options.
You can either invent a new entire way
to do copywriting, which I think someone
will do. Maybe I will do it. Maybe it'll
be Ben Settle. Maybe it'll be Daniel
Thrasell. Maybe it'll be Chris
Orzicowski. Somebody is going to invent
a new style of copywriting that is going
to stand out completely from the AI
world of copy. It's going to be new.
It's going to be fresh. It's going to be
attractive and people are going to flock
to it because it doesn't smell like
99.9% of the market. Smells like like a
used diaper filled with Indian food. the
demand for that new style of copywriting
will be incredibly high and whoever does
that will print cash because they will
be one of the most in demand copywriters
in the world. They will get completely
ripped off. Again, the market will
oversaturate. Somebody will zag the
other way. But the further I dig into
this, the more comfortable I actually
feel with the style of copywriting that
I've been writing for the last few
years. And I call it relational copy. I
actually swiped the influence from
people like Ben Settle, Daniel Thrasel
because these people have been writing
relational copy for the last 15, 20
years. Meaning it's not your typical
like features and benefits and premiums
and promos and sales and discounts and
all that stuff. While they do inject
some of that, their entire copywriting
structure and brand is built off
personal relationships, telling their
personal stories, writing in their
personal voice. And while this is a much
slower way to build a copywriting brand,
it is actually the most sustainable way
to build a copywriting brand because it
doesn't matter if the market is Zigg or
if the market is Zag. You are neither.
You are actually building a personal
relationship with the people who are
reading your stuff. And the market can't
swipe you anyway because it can't swipe
your stories and it can't swipe your
relationships and it can't swipe your
emotions. And so if you yourself don't
feel like scaling with AI and doing a
lot more for a lot cheaper and just
doing it out of scale and you don't feel
like building a brand new style of
copywriting that's going to be a
complete zag and throw the whole
industry in a loop, then the best thing
that I would recommend that you do to
not be replaced is start writing
relational copy. Start learning how to
tell your own stories. How to understand
your own emotions. Put them into words.
Build a relationship with people.
Understand the fundamentals of
copywriting. Inject those copywriting
fundamentals into your relational copy
and build a long-term brand selling your
own stuff, your own products, your own
offers, your own premiums. In fact, I
genuinely believe that the future of
copywriting is built with a bunch of
freelance copywriters who work for
themselves, who solve problems for
people who actually don't work at a
company or don't work for clients, but
actually work solo as an entrepreneur
creating their own world. This is
becoming more accessible than ever,
especially with the likes of YouTube and
email, SMS. Now, can you be a personal
brand that uses AI? Yes. But I wouldn't
recommend using AI in your copy because
then again, you're going Zigg. you're
doing what the rest of the market is
doing. You're going to look, feel,
smell, and sound like the rest of the
market. So, you're actually negating
your advantage. Can you use AI for your
business operations? Sure, for expenses
and all that other crap that you're
doing, IDA, whatever. But injecting it
into your copy as a relational
copywriter is actually again going to
negate your advantage. And if you want
to learn how to write relational copy
that is timeless and can be industry
proof from AI or whatever the new
copywriting is, then I've got a couple
options for you. Number one, you could
join my email list at allryoo.com. I
send a daily email every day. You could
jump in, read my stuff, see how I do it,
follow me, and use my daily emails as
inspiration and momentum for you to
build your own daily email list, tell
your own stories, and build your own
brand. Number two, if you're looking for
something a little bit more practical
and something you could get your hands
on today and start working, I sell a
course called Email Goat. I'm going to
put the link in the description below.
You could go grab that course. It is
paid. It's 147 bucks. It's 108 pages
worth of content that teaches you
exactly how to write relational copy.
But number three, if you want a
different resource that's not paid at
all, you could grab Copywriting
Catalyst. It's my 63 cash cow tips
copywriting guide. It's a bunch of tips
that you can read in 90 seconds or less
and really understand the fundamentals
of copywriting and relational
copywriting. Any one of those options
are going to be really helpful options.
A couple other people that I recommend
is Ben Settle and Daniel Thros. I
mentioned them both in this video. I'm
going to put their newsletter links in
the descriptions down below. Heads up,
they both send daily emails as well. So,
if you're subscribing to all three of
us, you might be bombarded. But all
three of us are freaking awesome. So,
you're really going to enjoy those
emails and you're going to learn a lot
about relational copy. Plus, kudos to
those guys. I really appreciate what
they do and I've learned so much from
them. Overall, those are my thoughts on
the copywriting industry and will
copyriters be replaced in 2025. Those
are your three paths. You're either
going to scale and do a lot more for a
lot less money and just handle a bunch
of clients and make money that way.
You're going to go right. You're going
to build something entirely new, sound
like nobody else, and absolutely blow up
the industry. or you're going to write
relational copy where you are a category
of one, a brand of one. Nobody can swipe
or steal you and you're just going to
build relationships over time. Any one
of those paths I believe are viable.
They're industry proof and I believe
they're genuinely going to help you a
ton. So, if you enjoyed this video, make
sure to like and subscribe to the
channel. It means so much if you like
and subscribe. I will continue to put
out free content like this. I will
continue to add free courses as well as
paid courses. Come on, you know that.
And anything else that I can help you
with. So, drop a comment on this video.
What did you enjoy? What do you want me
to make next? I appreciate it. And I'll
chat with you guys soon. Okay. Now, oh,
my spelling. Okay. Now, I want you to
rewrite it in the voice of
Goatman Gary
Bener. Dude, you think Claude's getting
mad at me? was I'd be happy to rewrite
this. He's like, "Yeah, no problem."
Gary Benzova is considered one of the
greatest copyright. That's why I said
the goat man, idiot. The overlooked
research that could double your response
rates almost overnight. Yeah, that
sounds like something Gary would say. A
special briefing for serious
professional copyright. Okay, some of
this
isn't all right. We're not that
cooked. I mean, we're like we're cooked,
but we're not that cooked. Why? Most
copyrightiting advice falls dangerously
short. Yeah, dude. We get it off for
proof as for sale. This advice isn't
[Music]
wrong. All right, we get it. We get it.
We're not that cook. Bye.